llegó el momento ahora sí estamos
preparados para resolver ecuaciones
diferenciales de segundo orden con
coeficientes constantes pero que sean no
homogéneas a qué me refiero con eso pues
bueno tener ecuaciones de la forma a por
jamie prima más b porque prima más c
porque por la función original y esto
igual dado a una función de x y es que
yo quiero contarles algo muy importante
lo importante es resolver la ecuación
homogénea encontrar su solución general
y encontrar la solución particular de
esta ecuación y si nosotros sumamos la
ecuación general de la ecuación
homogénea bueno sé que ésta no me
entienden mucho pero vamos a construirlo
poco a poco voy a suponer que h es la
solución general de mi ecuación
homogénea solución general de ecuación
homogénea qué quiere decir eso pues de
una ecuación de segundo orden que estaba
igualada 0 si h es solución de esta
ecuación homogénea
que se cumple pues que apura h mi prima
más ve por h prima ya éstos le sumábamos
ce veces h
esto tenía que ser igual a 0 recuerden
que cuando yo decía homogéneo estoy
hablando de una ecuación igualdad a cero
y si se acuerdan nosotros lo que
hacíamos en los vídeos anteriores era
encontrar la ecuación característica y
de esa ecuación característica ver sus
raíces y ver si eran reales serán
iguales sean distintas o inclusive si
eran completas pero si yo lo vimos en
los vídeos anteriores así que no me voy
a detener a analizar todo eso lo que sí
les quiero decir es que estoy suponiendo
que h es la solución general en ecuación
homogénea y ahora imagínense que yo me
encuentro a otra solución una solución
j&j para no consumir la congela cuando
nace una solución particular de ecuación
no homogénea es decir cumple que a por
jota mi prima más b por jota prima base
por j es igual a g
x dicho de otra manera j
es una función de x que cumple que es
una solución particular de mi ecuación
diferencial de segundo orden no
homogénea es una solución particular
pero yo lo que les quiero enseñar es que
jota y h sumadas es la solución general
de la ecuación diferencial no homogénea
y realmente lo que quiero hacer ahorita
es que tengamos un poco de intuición
antes de hacer los cálculos y veamos que
realmente si se va a cumplir esta
ecuación diferencial igualada gdx puesto
que si yo meto h + j pues por una parte
a por h
mi prima más b por h prima más d por h
pues me da 0 y si yo le agrego a j me va
a dar que de x y entonces esto me da
igual a gd x ahora vamos a hacer las
cuentas numéricamente que me va a quedar
a por h más j
mi prima pues es así mi prima más hot a
mi prima están de acuerdo la segunda
derivada de una suma de funciones pues
es la suma de las segundas derivadas
pasa lo mismo para la primera derivada
me va a quedar bien que multiplica a h
prima mascota prima más que multiplica a
h más jota bien ahora lo que voy a hacer
es distribuir tanto la a como la ve como
la hace y esto me va a dar de resultado
pues a por el chevy prima más b por h
prima más se emborrachen ya esto le voy
a sumar yo también estoy de una vez esté
metiendo en los términos semejantes a
por jota mi prima más b por jota prima
pues más por jota y como siempre recurro
a mi obsesión con los colores ya tengo
de amarillo todo lo que tiene que ver
con h todo esto pues como sabíamos que
dar solución de la homogénea pues es
igual a cero entonces realmente esto 0 y
por otra parte como nosotros seríamos
que jota era una función particular de
la homogénea a por jota mi prima más
bien por jota más se por j pues estamos
diciendo que esto es
entonces todo esto de aquí va a ser gtx
bien y gtx pues es igual a equis
entonces pues de acabe a cabo yo de
enseñarles que la suma de h mascota
cumplen ecuación diferencial de segundo
orden y lo que yo quiero decirles es que
si yo pongo una nueva solución llamada
acá y esta es ni más ni menos que hdx +
jd x lo que hemos dicho pero ya con un
nuevo nombre cada x es mi solución
general de la ecuación diferencial de
segundo orden no homogénea con
coeficientes constantes pero ustedes me
van a decir qué es lo que está pasando
aquí estoy un poco confundido lo
entiendo nada no se preocupen justo
ahorita lo que quiero hacer es un
ejemplo que tenga que ver con esta misma
ecuación no homogénea pero que tenga que
ver con números reales así que volvemos
todo y vamos a ver un ejemplo nuevo bien
ustedes se van a preguntar cómo es
posible que tú puedas sacar una solución
particular de su función diferencial no
homogénea como encuentra j pues en este
ejercicio creo que les va a quedar más
claro mi siguiente ejercicio va a ser
y a mi prima ya esto le voy a rezar tres
veces bien prima y yo creo que le voy a
quitar otra vez 4g y esto lo voy a hacer
a una función que tiene que ver con x 3
y 2 x pero antes de filosofar con la
jota lo primero que vamos a hacer es lo
que ya sabemos vamos a resolver la
ecuación homogénea mi ecuación homogénea
en este caso pues es mi prima menos 3 y
en prima -4 y como es homogénea está
igualada 0 y de aquí se acabamos su
ecuación característica que es cuadrada
menos tres r menos cuatro y esto se
puede actualizar estos ere menos cuatro
que multiplica a uno y esto es igual a
cero de lo que me primer raíces 4 y
segunda raíz es pues menos 17 mundos
raíces 4 y menos 1 y ya con las raíces
podemos encontrar la solución general de
inmigración diferencial homogénea le voy
a poner 10 subíndice que en lugar de h
es mucho más formal y entonces quien me
va a quedar pues es mi primer constante
por la 4x más mi segunda constante
al menos x porque me segunda raíz es
menos 1 esto ya lo hemos analizado en
todos los vídeos anteriores y aquí es
donde viene el conocimiento nuevo como
vamos a encontrar la jota o la
producción particular de una ecuación no
homogénea pues bien si no se han dado
cuenta este video se llama coeficientes
indeterminados 1 entonces el
procedimiento que voy a utilizar se
llama así pero tened en cuenta que por
intuición y tal vez con un poco de
colmillo matemático podemos ver que si
tenemos una segunda derivada más una
primera derivada más una función normal
y que nos dé tres veces a la 2 x pues me
suena que esto tiene que ver con
funciones exponenciales no conocemos lo
derivamos dos veces 11 nos lo derivamos
dos veces con su primera derivada y
nunca nos da un 2 x y un polinomio
tampoco
sean hiperbólico tampoco entonces creo
que mi solución particular tiene que ver
con una exponencial
bien pues resolución particular le voy a
poner el nombre de pepe en lugar de jota
pues para hacerla más formal y dese
cuenta que esta función particular tiene
que ver con el 2x de hecho tiene que ver
con la constante que multiplica a la 2x
porque si yo como una constante pues se
va a eliminar a la 2x tarde o temprano
recuerden que a la 2 x se su derivada
tiene que ver con ella misma entonces de
una vez hagamos la me va a quedar dos
veces a por ea la 2 x donde hay misma
constante y su segunda derivada pues es
4 veces a por él a la 2x y si yo tengo a
la 2 x en todos lados ahorita no voy a
poder cancelar pero antes que nada voy a
tratar de sustituir a ver si se
encuentra una solución particular es
decir la segunda derivada que es 4a por
ea la 2 x menos 3 veces la primera
derivada o sea menos 6
a por él a las 2 x 3 x 12 6
- cuatro veces la función original o sea
menos cuatro por dos equis y todo esto
tiene que ser igual a 3 por 2 x lo
primero que quiero que vean es lo que
les contaba era la 2x el factor común de
todo entonces lo podemos cancelar una
vez bien y me ese 4 al menos cuatro
vamos también no me sirve ahorita
entonces ya me queda una ecuación bien
sencilla de resolver menos 6 a es igual
a 3 y si yo resuelvo para qué era lo que
estaba buscando me queda que vale un
medio porque 3 entre 6 y es un medio
bien ya puedo sustituir yo a a aquí y
obtener resolución particular menos un
medio por el 2x y ya con esta solución
particular y mi solución general de la
parte homogénea entonces ya podemos
encontrar mi solución general de mi
ecuación diferencial no homogénea y esta
es la voy a denotar con jeff sin que ni
ver ni nada
esta es la suma de la general de la
homogénea es decir c1 x
a la 4 x + c 2 por el ala menos x
esta era la solución de la homogénea más
la particular o sea menos un medio de 2x
y es así como por fin ya encontramos la
solución general de lan homogénea darse
cuenta que yo propuse como una solución
particular algo que tenía que ver con el
2x porque tenía igualado
2x de hecho en los siguientes vídeos
vamos a ver funciones que no tengan que
ver con exponenciales tales polinómicas
trigonométricas pero nos veamos el
siguiente vídeo